ah
let's go i've impressed that paul walker
looked like he was handling his own with
tony jobs
right
everything you're watching is completely
1 000 practical done on a green screen
the funny thing is i also worked on this
film yes but i got to be a robot i went
to the hospital two times on this movie
really is there an injury that made you
go okay i'm done
this episode is brought to you by vessy
stick around to the end to see how you
can get 25 off their amazing everyday
move shoot hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of stuntman react i'm
here not only with our longtime friend
gee but travis is joining us for the
first time on the couch what's up guys
yep he taught me how to fall off the top
of this building and i was like maybe we
should talk about some cool clips man
i'm not gonna lie i have been waiting
years to get invited to sit on this
couch
and we finally made it happen i was
curious i was like are my credit's not
good enough like what i need to do to
get invited to corridor you guys right
so both these guys have some amazing
credits to the name it's amazing work
under their belt and i cannot wait to
show you guys some cool clips and also
to see some of the stuff that you've
worked on and get some stories from the
inside there are definitely some stories
some that i would like to forget and
some that i will never forget so let's
get into it sweet
we can take him you said so yourself
we're not ready so we're starting with a
dance scene
this is not just any dance scene though
nico do you know why this is important
this is actually my first ever feature
film that i ever did which i actually
got contacted by the director to come in
to do one day of reshoots they had shot
the entire movie in new york city yeah
right actually i worked on this film as
well as a dancer as a dancer yeah and so
they brought us back in for reshoots for
this one epic scene you guys about to
see where i made my money boom right
there don't blink you just missed
it that was my introduction into the
feature film world um right there in
that one second there it is doing a full
twist with the kick yeah you can kind of
see the face yeah and then i do the full
twist of the kick and then my friend
does a kick into a full twist so we're
kind of doing like a opposite move but
what is cool though is of all the people
in the world all of our friends that are
like world renowned trickers that is the
first time that the word tricker was
credited in a motion picture
a little bit of history and luckily this
came out in 2010 because 2011 is when
the kick came out you guys know the kick
you never seen the kick what you've
never seen the kick that's the kick we
have to bring that christian pull up the
kick
so basically the kick was cool because
it was on the first time that they
really featured like martial arts
tricking cinematically how would you
define tricking so tricking is an
aesthetic blend of martial arts combined
with elements of acrobatics break
dancing gymnastics it's basically taking
like elements of every single sport and
adding the most aesthetically pleasing
combinations together it's basically
like real life street fighter okay
awesome
without making contact until you see
until you see this yeah i mean obviously
this dude came to fight he's moonwalking
[Laughter]
i mean what's more embarrassing than
getting kicked a side flip to a kick
followed by a dance move right right
yeah i just feel so bad for these guys
over there they're literally just crash
test dummies just lining up to get
kicked in the face right there
straight up look at this
can't fake that there was no stack on
that hit none
a little hilton bosch for those who like
to dance
man i mean how have you not seen this
movie
this is great this is so classy i love
seeing like cool new scenes on this show
that i've never seen before and just
being like whoa this exists yeah it's
out there yo i know a lot of people are
freaking out about andy lee and shang
chi going crazy well this is 2011 you
guys hey yo andy lee step your game
up it's not the best kick bro i love you
to death 10 years later bro and you got
to do the double variation now
i need three kicks yes yes yes
i was born to be a vampire
yeah we went from dancing to vampires
right this was actually my first movie
run and a movie run is when you go on a
film for the entire duration of the
filming production so i'd worked on
films for like a day a week and stuff
like this but i was on this phone for
three and a half months of my life
chris brewster in there yo brewster
latif holland diaz aaron tony rich the
troll
here
yeah aaron tony's in here it's probably
two date one of the craziest stunt teams
that i've ever been a part of
so here's me getting my arm ripped off
get thrown by holland diaz and boom
ripped an arm off
and what's funny is two minutes later i
get my other arm ripped off by another
girl it's kind of like glorified
background fighting in this because
there's so much chaos happening that
we're just fighting in the background
but some of the craziest wire gags that
are happening and you're just not seeing
it i remember aaron tony did an air ram
to dead man which is literally stepping
off an air ram being tied to a line
that's a dead man so it limits him oh my
god and what's crazy is it was the start
of a mass chaos shot that pulls out so
every time we cut he had to do it no
matter what i don't know and uh you
can't see it in the final movie
you can't see it of course was he at
least landing on a pad he was landing on
a pad covered in snow but that's one of
those gags where it just sucks it's the
dead man that hurts yeah yeah especially
with the ram i also still find it very
funny that the fight coordinator of this
movie is jeff amada who's like a
legendary fight coordinator known for
his martial arts powers and ability and
uh he's doing background fights on a
twilight movie
talk about over qualification on the
right
sorry sir you're overqualified for this
job yeah
so you're one of the wolves too right so
the wolves is what's crazy what you guys
would appreciate the wolves are actually
cardboard cutouts that are carried
around by production assistants who run
carrying cardboard and when they eat
people they shake it at you and you have
to be pretending that this cardboard is
eating you i can't imagine that pa
running at the cargo was at all useful
for production none of this is used this
is completely useless yeah securities
already
uh finally some real stunts yeah there
we go finally some real stunts
this one i went on to right off the back
end of twilight it was another one i
went on to with aaron i remember getting
called and being told i was gonna be a
ninja so for a month of preparation i
was running around my gym practicing
with the sword doing wall flips doing
all kinds of tricks and we show up and
it's just a green screen wall and they
go did you bring your harness and i go
yeah this entire scene is wire work
you're going to be on a wire for the
next four months of your life oh my gosh
then to make things even crazier they
then show up with this cinematic previz
we watched and we're like oh that's
really funny and they literally go no
you're going to recreate every move in
this animation
we literally did everything in this
movie practical
everything you're watching is completely
1 000 practical done on a green screen
it was not an easy scene by any means i
went to the hospital two times on this
movie really before i did the most
memorable one i do a scene where i'm
fighting snake eyes i jump off the wall
and he's supposed to do a 180 turn and
cut my wire and my character falls down
this one right here so it's supposed to
be right there where it cuts the oh i
see but as you guys see yeah hit me in
the head at full speed
while being on wires on a wench going 30
miles an hour at each other so when you
combine speed and force and a weapon
sounds like a lot of blood everywhere uh
yeah which at first i didn't know at
first i got hit and i just got knocked
out unconscious and the reason i woke up
was aaron tony yelled yo t you good i
was like uh i think so and then he goes
oh no you're bleeding i'm like
uh-oh
but of course we're in red ninja outfits
right so i can't see anything until they
put me down on the line as soon as they
take my hood off buckets of blood all
over on the ground yeah i'm not gonna
lie though it's pretty cool the person
they got to with me is the iconic
ill-rom choi right so i get to say hey
man i got doubled by overall he's been
on the couch yeah he's been on the couch
100 man
we have a special cameo oh
mama wong everybody that's my mom that's
your mom that's my mom
[Music]
what a gangster this is what a common
argument in the long household looks
like
people wonder why i was such a good kid
and got straight away
[Laughter]
yeah it's crazy man even in that movie
when she did that she was 55 doing her
own fight scene in that movie right
there wow i have no excuses right what'd
you do today that's my question sat on a
couch to talk to you guys reminisced on
how cool we used to be before we got
hurt
before we broke ourselves before we got
broken is there an injury that made you
go okay i'm done there is not one
specific injury that made me choose to
quit but there was one film that
actually got me to the point where i
decided to get to the other side of the
camera and that was a little film by the
name of transformers for age of
extinction
[Music]
so in that scene a robot's going to pick
up a bus by magnet lift it up and then
tilt it over and we're supposed to fall
out on the day when we rehearsed it it
was a bus with no windows all pads on
the ground so they lifted the bus up and
we'd all just flip out and fall to the
ground onto the mats we show up on the
day and the bus has limo tinted windows
which means we can't see how high above
the ground we are and during the scene
there are stunt people running under us
so you have no idea if you're going to
fall out and land on top of somebody
there's the bus ball
did you see that no that last guy that
fell was sam locke who is one of the
most gangster guys in the stunt industry
he fell from probably nine to ten feet
high straight to his face dislocated his
shoulder and the camera car had to
physically stop right in front of him
before hitting him this was just crazy
sam is about to fall see that dude on
the vest on the ground right there
that's me i jumped
early i jumped hell earlier out of there
and then the other two guys that are
hanging in there they're strapped in so
they didn't get to fall i was like man
must be nice
i'll never forget the scene started with
eight people i think maybe seven take
one guy cut his head open went to the
hospital take two guy cut his arm open
went to the hospital take three a guy
dislocated his shoulder went to the
hospital
take four i'm looking around the room
and i'm like
there's three of us left like who is
next and that's michael bay's squid game
but we did not make that much money
the funny thing is i also worked on this
film yes but i got to be a robot
i'd have to go and jump out of buses or
anything like that no anxiety attacks on
that one i was galvatron that is why i
have no fear
i got to go to ilm up in san francisco
and do all these cool fights must be
nice yeah i had the kush job while you
were once while you were watching your
fellow comrades exactly get taken out
bit by bit working on michael babe films
you definitely know what you're doing
when you enter into those like if you
have no idea then that's just kind of
your fault at this point right i will
say this though like the stunt
coordinators on these jobs are always
doing their best to handle the beast of
the michael bay project to make sure
it's as safe as possible and there's
just always an inherent risk factor the
one thing i will say is cool about
michael is that he does get into the mix
himself so you know the one thing i do
respect is that even though he demands a
lot he's willing to put himself in the
line yeah he's not like telling you to
go and do this stuff and he's saying in
video village nice and cush with
somebody massaging his feet he's in
there with you so you're kind of like i
guess i can do this yeah
yeah i got a ton more clips just like
the one you guys just saw featured here
be sure to subscribe so you can see what
else we got in store for you okay so you
were a performer right and then you're
like well the performing thing is cool
but i'm always very close to dying i
don't want to do that anymore dude but i
still want to be a part of this of this
industry of this world and do this kind
of stuff what was the next step that you
did let's not even lie let's just be
fully transparent i was on transformers
for i got a call from jeff amato who
said hey i'm gonna do a little movie
called fast and furious seven will you
be my assistant fight coordinator i was
like
i'm out of here i immediately left
transformers hopped onto fast and fury 7
in atlanta and this was the transition
to the next stage of my career as a
previz guy and an assistant fight
coordinator
the iconic paul walker versus tony
jossie oh yeah you know what's so funny
about this scene too when i read the
script you're going gonna take the one
guy who does all wide shots runs around
does flips and kicks and put him in the
smallest set possible and make him fight
in it and they're like hey can you show
all the signature moves i'm like how
we're in a bus
right
in order to pull this off i have to give
a lot of props to jeff amada who is the
fight coordinator he basically did a lot
of like trapping stuff which tony jaws
are really known for he's known for a
lot of like you know muay thai styles
big elbows big knees but in this we did
elements of trapping which jeff amada is
known for from his jeet kune do
background and paul walker man
so much could be said about this guy but
this guy was the first to show up at
rehearsals last to leave it's always
nice to hear about like actors that are
like that dedicated to the game yeah
i've impressed that paul walker looked
like he was handling his own with tony
jobs that's what i'm saying right it'd
be very hard to look like you could
handle your own attorney job 100
when he showed up and did the work
that's what makes it even cooler it's
not double work it's paul walker showing
up and and doing
like i'm gonna get it done vision hubs
right
that's right so this scene was super
unique and i'll never forget it because
it was the first time i ever got the
chance to work with the rock he showed
up on day one of rehearsal and i'm like
all right dwayne we're gonna like walk
through it and he's like i do this there
i do this there he tackles me through
there and i literally go
you know the whole fight and i'll never
forget this he's put his hand on my
shoulder goes i just do 30 minute live
shows little brother this is two minutes
so badass
but what was unique about this was this
was our first fight scene for the entire
production so it really set the tone for
the whole film and what was crazy about
it was that on day one of principal
photography our lead stunt double for
the rock had to go into the hospital
into emergency surgery shout out to ton
of water shout out to tonight reed the
rock stunt double and cousin yeah and
his cousin
right there oh man so what happened was
he got tackled through that glass window
right the glass is real it's loaded with
a charge of pyrotechnics that someone on
the effects team will pop right at the
right time so that it shatters the glass
and then your force going through it is
what actually breaks it so what hurt him
was when he lands on the table he lands
on top of glass it basically shoved into
his arm almost cut an artery right here
in his arm and he had to go literally
into emergency surgery right away we're
only halfway through the fight scene on
day one so we literally had to call in a
favor on a guy that was a stand-in for
the rock on hercules fly him in
emergency overnight teach him how to do
fight scenes teach him how to do the
rock bottom and what's cool is you fast
forward now to like five years later
that guy is one of the rock stunt
doubles oh really yeah yeah on like some
crazy double scale contract or something
you know making money yeah having worked
with a couple like bigger dudes like the
rock i've never seen people who are more
disciplined in exacting with their work
and their job than people who do action
and are also incredibly physically fit
at the same time
but yeah honestly in my personal opinion
the fights are literally what has
brought fast and furious fans back to
like a grounded reality and i think
that's why they're putting so much
emphasis on the fights you know because
the car stuff has just become almost
like comical
right you can't do that you can't fly a
car like that you know but the fight
scenes are one of the more realistic
things i guess you could say as we watch
the rock about to fall out of a window
50 feet onto the top of a car
and survive
obviously you're both huge fans of
action but is there a realm of like
stunt work that you're like you know
what i want to see some cool stunts of
this type i personally would like to see
if anyone out there knows of any other
tricking choreography that exists i
would love to see if there's any
overseas films that people know about
that feature more acrobatics that we've
never seen along with that i'd also like
to see more ninja stuff i feel like
ninjas got a bad rep in the 90s so
you're saying that surf ninjas wasn't uh
very appreciative or yeah nobody
appreciates that movie i love that movie
do not talk bad on surf ninjas that was
my childhood what's wrong let's hide
let's kick some but
not to mention that has one of the
biggest stair falls yeah
yeah y'all don't know about the
stairfall i didn't i didn't know about
this that's gotta be an episode of
himself that's another episode for sure
hey guys it's me back again to tell you
about today's sponsor bessie and why
i've been doing stunts in their
everyday moves they're the everyday
sneaker for you and let me tell you why
for all you people who don't live in los
angeles there's this thing called
weather it happens in most other parts
of the world and that means that the
thing on your foot is going to be
trouncing through mud snow water what
have you and guess what with the
everyday move you can not only wear
these every day they're 100 waterproof
and go through almost any different type
of weather condition you could put
your favorite pet mouse in here
with a little cozy blanket
pose down the shoe
pull him back out again let him go into
the world and he'd be
he wouldn't even know he wouldn't even
know
too bad for you you took your designer
shoes through a wet puddle now you gotta
spend five days cleaning them off take
them to a specialist with the vessy
everyday moves you just throw these into
the washing machine you take them out
you set them out to dry you put them on
again and then boom there they are again
so it is new ready to go so these really
are truly the everyday sneaker and if
that's not enough for you these shoes
also are made from a patented dimetex
material which keeps you cool in the
summer and warm in the winter and
they're sustainably made they use less
water waste than most other sneaker
manufacturers and they use no animal
byproducts meaning that they're vegan so
if you've been inspired by this show and
you want a shoe that can keep up with
you through training or exercise or just
everyday out and about the vessi
everyday move is one of the perfect
shoes for you and you can get 25 off
right now by going to vesty.com corridor
crew that's vesey.com corridor crew you
can get this sneaker right here or any
of the other beautiful sneakers that
they have get moving travis and gee it's
been a pleasure thank you so much for
joining us travis what do you got going
on if people want to you know check out
some more of this stuff yeah if you guys
want to stay up to date with my personal
journey you can check out my instagram
at the travis wong and more than
anything i am a co-owner of joining all
movement alongside aaron tony so if you
guys want to follow us check us out on
youtube at joining all movement or ja
movement on instagram you guys know who
it is i'm he's a silva you can find me
on instagram i changed my name recently
it's my whole name now d the silver
green you guys keep hitting me up about
coming back i'm not in charge of that
so if you want me to come back and be on
this amazingly comfortable green couch
bother
nico
you can follow me on instagram at niko
direct dms there
yeah i'm like hell yeah i can't wait to
be on stun and react again they're like
when are you gonna be i can't wait man
when it happens i'll be here
hey it took me two years so uh what do
you complain about bro thank you guys
for having me i appreciate it it's been
an absolute pleasure guys thank you so
much
[Music]